so a lot of girls would say that pc is
one it's really 20.
[Music]
because they know that because they know
but that's actually some girls some
girls will like saying that their bc is
one and if you're oh that's calm you get
to know her and then
she's really really like putting all the
tricks
gonna start in it because like they know
that the type of guy you are you're not
going to deal with a girl that's like
out there so they're going to have to
lie to you but you that's something you
never know
yeah you should be open from the start
but i guess you can't avoid in certain
situations mm-hmm
but okay so
bc is one thing right
like like a girl what's what she's done
but i think it takes it to another level
when it's on the internet like i have
brothers i would never tell them to deal
with a girl that has any sort of only
fans any sort of sex tape on the
internet like ever
because like your kids are going to see
that one day
and like that's what you're seeing now
with kim kardashian like look at the
like the she has to have that
conversation with all four of her kids
so can you imagine having a mom with an
off like an only fans
[Music]
that's a really that's a really specific
like
how do you know the truth
no but like
no but if we're talking about like kim k
of course like
her sex tape is going to be out there
because she's really up there but if
we're talking about like a normal person
i think it's gonna go away you're not
gonna like find a video like of someone
that you don't really know about mm-hmm
i think things definitely like brush
over like think think about coming along
i think about school at times stuff gets
sent around that's like now do you even
remember that no look look at oshkosh
bro now
[Music]
[Music]
i think there's exceptions to every rule
right but
it's still like in general like i just
don't know why as a guy you'd want to
deal with that do you think that guys
put up with like bad behavior because a
chick is like really good looking some
people do yeah i think it's more easier
to look over yeah you know like let's
say like you bagged
let's see
let's see you've had one lengthening now
and it's like the girl's toxic but
because she's lengthy you know like if
you have her by your side i'm animal
like yeah i rate your thing so when you
go behind closed doors she might be so
toxic like bro like no one's meant to be
going through that but because she's
laying down she that's what you're like
you're putting up with it because you
just want to keep her there did you get
it
so yeah
i think a lot of guys care about like
other like guys validating them that's
why they put up with it
and that's all stems from but even now
like girls of bad behavior like all that
toxic [ __ ] like it's normalized now so
a lot of guys tend to look for that now
it's just crazy yeah some guys like it
man i have been saying that every show
that i think there's a type of guy that
likes girls that are a little bit mean
to them
yeah they're i mean and keep them keen
like no but i don't
like dad next question question no like
no it will i just like will smith okay
take will smith take no no let's let's
just use him as an example okay
you you cannot you can
you can't you cannot tell me that will
smith did not have the option to pick a
girl that was nice to him when he was on
the fresh prince of freaking bel-air he
he could have had his pick of what like
lined up
and he picked the one girl
that like is borderline and like abusive
to him mentally she was in love with
tupac yeah she was in love with someone
else well you're shown like at the
beginning because like what you're
showing like what someone decides to
show you could be completely different
than what they really are do i mean it's
like years down the line it could be
tomorrow but it could be years down she
was like crying on their wedding day
what do you mean
so look how long they would have been
for and obviously there's signs and
stuff but like yeah if you like it you
like it
yeah
now will smith went up on the stage
actually smacked some of her and she
said that she still did all that with a
madness like that's crazy i could never
have a goal that like i'd do that for my
man just listen no yes mama made a joke
about your your your head
no no no
i'm not trying to violently no mama made
a joke about your head
no no but no but keep it cool that's one
thing another guy went into your wife
you could even tuck him down to do
nothing like i can't let your waist man
no no violence i'll be so real will
smith i love fresh fruits and vegetables
like that's my guy but after i saw that
and i saw everything
there's levels to that you're not gonna
go for the guy bro what are you gonna go
for the guy first her bro but that's
what i'm saying if you're not gonna go
for the guy that went into your wife
don't go for no one that chats about
your wife bro yeah i think there's
there's levels in it yeah you sat right
there
he was set right there
with your wife bro and someone said joel
you know it's a little bit more than
just yeah
but bro but there's a bit more in the
marriage you still let bro you bro your
wife told you in your face on flipping
the whole world knew it bro
you bro i dropped another guy because
what i needed some sort of security yeah
but whether he made the house he bought
a house for her bro whether you move one
pasta it's like that's different what
what i'm saying to you is let's say
you're sitting there with your wife
right now and i make a joke a personal
joke but to you to me that's what chris
is meant to do you know yeah he
literally is on the show to present
that's
if you take it how you take it he
literally does that for a living
everyone has to know something this was
right i'm just saying yeah in terms of
like defending her or going to suffolk
chris rock supposed to know she had
alopecia he doesn't care you just have
to phone me handed it differently but
even if you message yourself
by not slapping a grown man on this like
when he grabbed his oscar whatever it is
tell everyone that look that was not
okay mm-hmm like in front of everyone
that he could have
but like
he was just acting up he was acting out
a character like yo
you just trying to prove a point
in the moment and you think after things
like maybe a bit too much do you want to
but it happens bro yeah no
but like maybe if you're like
you know 18 but
i'm sorry if like a grown ass man you
don't you you're not in control enough
of your emotions
you don't have to like you don't have to
put up with that she [ __ ] and like
like imagine imagine okay if jada was a
dude okay and and or let's say will
smith did it he hooks up with a 20 year
old
that is addicted to drugs that they took
in from the time she was like 15. she
was like 15. and then he sleeps with her
all right
like you don't you think the world would
have like
no he would be done yeah and it's such a
double standard
yeah
and it's like like she's almost i would
say predatory to be honest an
entanglement she said
an entanglement that would
she give it a whole different meaning